[Music]
welcome to cbs this morning on this
monday morning we're going to begin with
this
a dramatic new development could
threaten one of president trump's
defenses in the house impeachment
inquiry
a second whistleblower has come forward
claiming to have firsthand knowledge of
the president's july 25 phone call
with the president of ukraine a lawyer
for the new whistleblower said the
person made a protected disclosure and
cannot be retaliated against the
president brushed it off on twitter
saying keep them coming wijajang is at
the white house weisha
does the new whistleblower change the
president's approach to the impeachment
inquiry it doesn't sound like it
good morning tony you are right the
president's personal attorney tells cbs
news that this does not change their
legal strategy
and the white house press secretary says
it doesn't matter how many people come
forward as whistleblowers
because president trump did nothing
wrong but for democrats this means
another key witness
as their as they build their case for
impeachment
the new whistleblower could blow up
president trump's main
argument against the original
whistleblower the whistleblower never
saw the
saw the conversation he got his
information i guess second to third hand
the white house has argued that
whistleblower number one is not credible
because he
or she said in a formal complaint i was
not a direct witness to most of the
events described
instead multiple officials recounted
fact patterns that were consistent with
one another
in other words she didn't know what was
on the call no these are bad
people these are dishonest people but
the latest person calling out the
president apparently has
first-hand knowledge of the july 25
phone call
in which mr trump asked ukrainian
president vladimir zelinski to
investigate unsubstantiated claims
against joe biden and his son hunter
democrats say for dirt to use in his
reelection campaign
congressman jim hymes is on the house
intelligence committee
people around the president
professionals who are in the oval office
who are
in the situation room are watching what
is happening and are finally saying my
god this cannot happen anymore
and while he continues to publicly
describe his conversation with zielinski
as perfect
cbs news has learned in private
president trump is playing the blame
game
telling republican lawmakers he only
called because energy secretary rick
perry
asked him to not once not once as god is
my witness not once
was a biden name not the former vice
president not his son
ever mentioned in a statement perry's
spokesperson said that he absolutely
encouraged and supported president trump
to talk to zielinski
about energy security and economic
development now the democrats have
subpoenaed
him for documents related to
communications and traveled to ukane
it's part of the bigger effort to get
information from the white house and the
committees that issued that subpoena
set a deadline anthony for october 18th
all right we just thank you